and finally new rules someone must
explain Herschel Walker
and how in a supposedly sophisticated
country a person with his resume could
ever be elected to office although the
answer might be a little more
complicated than you think for the past
month there's been a lot written about
how Republicans standing behind a guy
like Walker means they've lost all sense
of integrity
really just now
[Applause]
died a long time ago after a long battle
with tribalism
Integrity is survived by hypocrisy and
fear of the other party
now of course
of course I could make a long string of
jokes about how unfit for office Walker
is and I think I will
[Applause]
if you have not been following this
story you need to know where to begin
well first of all he's just a [ __ ]
idiot on a scale almost impossible to
parody
although we did once present his book
called Herschel Walker science talker
as he says things like if man descended
from apes why are there still Apes
then there's the lying and the crazy and
the violence not only did he write a
book about having 12 different
personalities he wrote it with two other
people
[Applause]
he admits that he used to play Russian
Roulette he used to threaten to blow his
wife's brains out a lot and seems to
have never met a family member he hasn't
threatened to kill he threatened to kill
his girlfriend and he stalked a Dallas
Cowboys Cheerleader but that was just to
get Ron DeSantis her boots
laughs
he has threatened to shoot cops he
claimed to be a cop he wasn't claimed to
be an FBI agent wasn't claimed to be
valedictorian of his high school wasn't
claimed to graduate in the top one
percent of his class never graduated
claimed to have once supervised six
hospitals which is amazing given the job
he had with the FBI
foreign
hit he tried to sell a dry missed
coveted cure that would quote kill any
covet on your body
because one of his personalities is Dr
Oz
and just since the campaign began three
secret children have been Unearthed and
one of his kids says of Herschel he has
four kids four different women wasn't in
the house raising one of them
yeah he's very pro-family just not his
he's 100 against abortion no exceptions
but his girlfriend has proof he paid for
hers
then he got her pregnant again and tried
to get her to abort that one his
campaign slogan has stopped me before I
kill again
if you're thinking where have I seen
this man before you have President
Dwayne Elizondo Mountain Dew Camacho
from the movie Idiocracy
so why do Republicans stand by him now
the easy answer is they're deplorables
ignorant and bad and yes there is some
of that
I'm sorry if I'm going to stay in
America and America is going to stay
America I can't write off half the
country that easily also I talk to
deplorables
so let me try to translate not endorse
but translate for Liberal America
part of the appeal of a Herschel Walker
or a Donald Trump or any number of
egregious [ __ ] Republicans have
backed is in their mind the worse a
candidate is the more it says to
Democrats do you see how much we don't
like what you're selling
all that socialism and identity politics
and victimhood and oversensitivity and
cancel culture and white self-loathing
and forcing complicated ideas about race
and sex on kids too young to understand
it literally anything would be better
than that
that's their View
that's why you can be a really bad dude
in Republican politics and it's not a
deal breaker Judge Roy Moore was in his
30s when he was still going to the mall
and picking up teenage girls
Eric greitens was Missouri governor then
this year a Senate candidate despite the
fact that his ex-wife says he beat her
and the kids and he was charged with
tying up a woman he was having an affair
with taking nude pictures and
threatening to blackmail her with them I
mean Andrew Cuomo was creepy but there
was no begging to be untied
thank you
Al Franken took a gag picture but he
didn't go Phil Spector on anybody
[Applause]
this is a clear difference between the
parties Democrats also think the other
side is an existential threat but their
response is not to nominate sickos to
make a point
if it was they have a guy who'd fit the
bill
[Applause]
but they don't nominate him because that
would just be trolling
here's a question
is this person trolling
[Laughter]
this is a transgender teacher in Ontario
who made news last month when the school
supported her right to come to school
and teach children with these tits
[Applause]
so sure she isn't doing
due to make a statement that anyone can
do absolutely anything in the name of
wokeness and the left will never stop
them and that's when Republicans say
well then we'll have to no matter who we
have to elect to do it the fact that
Republicans have no shame in their game
and will vote for any monster with an R
by his name is their way of signaling
how serious they are about blocking this
[ __ ] they're like the bad guy in action
movies who shoots one of his own men wow
and then he's like I liked him but I had
to make a point